toy sorry is coming out have you seen
the finished products in the finished
project I laughed I cried I was inspired
it I've seen them all yeah I know I'm
partial you're gonna dance with your
favorite my favorite I got two Tony Hale
is unbelievable in this thing Christina
Hendricks other people I can't tell you
Mike I'm gonna ruin the surprise it's so
good it's so action-packed
it's and there are new old characters
coming back that you that we learn new
things about whose lives have changed
it's gonna be amazing and lying and
lying I get to play one of the hyenas
that's that's a dream roll yeah and it's
me you know the funny thing is I was
thought please I can't be ed I gotta
have actual dialogue I can't just be the
meth head I was like III would I would
be honored right but if I could just
have a couple of lines no but it works
you can't even imagine how this thing's
gonna look when you see the photo
realistic treatment they've given to it
is amazing it's more dangerous more
grave more funny and more Beyonce more
and more Beyonce more more Donald and
Beyonce I can't this thing's gonna make
us quit trillion dollars not only is
keegan-michael key busy with animated
projects he's also got some real-life
ones too
like NAT Gio's reboot of brain games
which he'll be hosting alongside some
celeb yes it is a show about the human
mind and every show has its own theme so
there'll be a show called battle of the
sexes they'll be a show called potential
versus grown-ups there'll be a show
called
delusion illusion so it's all about the
different parts of the brains how they
work how we react to things what we
think we see when we don't see it and
and it's and it's and it's going to be
manifested through us doing games with
celebrities like that Shepard and
Kristen Bell and rebel Wilson and Drew
Brees and people of this sort so they're
gonna be going through exercises with me
that show the human and it's gonna be
great because it's interactive right
it's a game to show
show that kids can watch with their
parents it shows that young people can
learn the tricks and do it bars it's got
everything
[Music]